une arrestation qui a secoué
l'opposition en géorgie ni camélia
leader du mouvement national uni a été
délogé mardi matin des locaux de sa
formation politique afin d'être placé en
détention provisoire
une arrestation musclée et violente des
centaines de policiers ont fait usage de
bombes lacrymogènes contre tous les
partis d'opposition qui campaient devant
le bâtiment
les militants du parti ont immédiatement
dénoncé cette arrestation
nous avons assisté à l'arrestation du
plus grand chef du parti d'opposition
dans ses propres locaux sous le prétexte
le plus cynique en utilisant les
instruments les plus honteux et
évidemment c'est un défi pour l'avenir
et la liberté de ce pays
il est de notre devoir en tant que
citoyen en tant que société de résister
en manifestant dans les rues par des
manifestations pacifiques mais très
intense
des milliers de manifestants sont
descendus dans les rues de géorgie pour
protester contre l'arrestation denis
camélia dans un contexte de crise
politique qui pourrait fragiliser un peu
plus la démocratie
en effet depuis les élections
législatives d'octobre 2020 les
différents partis d'opposition dénoncent
un scrutin truqué
bref géorgien le parti au pouvoir avait
revendiqué une courte victoire alors que
sa popularité décline sur fond de
stagnation économique et de dénonciation
d'atteintes à la démocratie lundi le
parlement a confirmé la nomination par
rêve géorgien d'irak ligali bages vili
au poste de premier ministre qui a
immédiatement annoncé l'arrestation
denis camélias le gouvernement a de son
côté évoqué un usage proportionné de la
force et la polarisation d'une politique
due à des délinquants
le premier ministre géorgien appelle
tous les partis de l'opposition au
dialogue et à l'apaisement
aujourd'hui le ministère de l'intérieur
a appliqué une loi nécessaire à la
réduction du radicalisme politique et à
l'établissement de relations équitables
quand les armes le match la réaction du
peuple à l'application de la loi a
confirmé que l'état de droit est la
principale priorité du peuple géorgien
concept shona lowe et whitman est
assiégé cependant nous
contourne pas le nombre de personnes
rassemblées pour la manifestation chaque
citoyen de notre pays nous est précieux
presse lors des hasards son vainqueur
aujourd'hui maintenant que la loi est
appliquée que l'état a pris la place qui
lui est due
je voudrais appeler toutes les forces
politiques qui tiennent à notre pays à
ouvrir un dialogue réel et sérieux times
appelle au dialogue et à parler non pas
de ce qui nous divise mais de ce qui
doit nous unir le pays est confronté à
des défis il est temps de dialoguer pas
de se confronter de loi ni camélia est
accusé d'avoir organisé des violences de
masse lors de manifestations en 2019 et
risque neuf ans de prison
des accusations qu'ils réfutent et juge
politique la scène internationale se dit
inquiète pour l'équilibré du pays la
violence et le chaos à tbilissi sont la
dernière chose dont la géorgie a besoin
en ce moment
j'exhorte tous les partis à agir avec
retenue maintenant et dans les jours à
venir
la décision d'arrêter un opposant
politique avait la semaine dernière
inquiéter l'union européenne et les
etats-unis appelant à séparer le système
judiciaire de tout parti pris politique
ce vendredi l'opposition appelle à une
nouvelle marche à tbilissi